hello and welcome to this uh itcs long
recorded talk on downward
self-reducibility in tfnp my name is
Daniel mitrapalski and this is Joint
work with my co-authors prahlad Harsha
and Alon Rosen and this work actually
emerged through a series of
conversations that prologue and I were
having with the London we were visiting
him in Milan and so actually this
presentation is going to mirror our
conversations uh and how we would
realize something and then ask kind of
the next obvious question and figure
that out or not and so it'll sort of
mirror the development of um of this
visit and how we got to this work
so what is downward self-reducibility
um sort of a reminder from this you may
have seen this definition a long time
ago a language L is downward
self-reducible or DSR if there exists a
polytime algorithm a deciding whether a
string X is an L with an oracle for L
but on sub queries that are strictly
smaller in length than x
okay
so here are some examples uh sat is DSR
and here's a very simple proof sketch
given a Boolean formula on N variables
X1 through xn we're going to query uh
two sub queries at most first we'll
query Phi where we set the first
variable X1 to zero so what that means
is we go into the formula everywhere
where X1 occurs we replace it with zero
and then simplify the formula so if
something is a
an and of X1 another variable well we'll
set that to zero and remove that clause
and so on so we remove it everywhere and
for this reason this sub query is
actually going to be smaller in length
than the original Phi okay and if that's
true we return true but if it's false we
do one more sub query and it's the one
where we set the first variable to one
okay now here's another uh proposition
not just sat but in fact tqbf or true
Quantified Boolean formulas the P space
complete problem is DSR all right and
the proof is the same the proof is that
if Phi begins with let's say all uh over
X1 well then we'll query two sub queries
we'll query the one where we set x one
to zero and we'll query the one where we
set x one to one and go into the formula
and actually remove X1 everywhere
thereby shortening the formula in each
case
all right and analogously for if it
begins with an existential quantifier
great so those are two problems that are
uh downward self-reducible uh and
several other NP as well as piece based
complete problems are DSR but there are
NP and P space complete problems that we
do not know whether they are trsr and
we'll talk more about that later
but we know that conversely if a problem
is DSR a problem here again means a
decisional problem of language is DSR
then it is in P space
interesting and the proof of this is
very simple you know because it's DSR it
has a very inefficient recursive
algorithm where you query smaller
strings and smaller and smaller strings
and so on but it is polynomial space
so you can kind of work that out but
what does it mean what does it mean if a
complete problem of a Class C has a
property p
and having the property P places you in
C
right having the property P doesn't mean
that you are complete for C that was the
case you would have a property P that is
equivalent to completeness and C right
so one consequence of having these two
conditions is the following all right
the consequence is that P space is hard
which means there exists a hard language
in P space
where hardness can be in any sense
either worst case or average case with
respect to samplable distributions or
computable distributions whatever you
want
is equivalent to a DSR language being
hard with hardness and meant in the
exact same sense
okay that's sort of one interpretation
of having a complete problems of a class
have a property p as well as that
property imply membership in the class
all right so in other words like you can
characterize hardness of p-space instead
is hardness of DSR languages which I
think is quite neat
now in most of this talk we will be
talking about and interested in
um search problems so what are search
problems uh they're not decisional uh
languages where we have to Output 0 1
but outputs can be strings of
arbitrary length but in general
polynomial length so uh here's an
important definition FNP for functional
NP is the class of efficiently
verifiable search problems
okay
whereas tfnp is the class of problems in
FNP that are total and total means that
for every possible input string there is
at least one solution that is accepted
by the verifier the verifier is the one
implied by the definition of FNP the one
that verifies Solutions
so an example here are two important
examples uh one is fsat for functional
sat that's the problem of finding a
satisfying assignment to a Boolean
formula right it's an FNP we can
efficiently verify candidate's solution
but it's not in tfnp because there are
unsatisfiable formulas right another
example is factoring given an integer n
a solution is either the word Prime if n
is Prime and note that we can
efficiently check if that's the correct
solution or its set of non-trivial
factors okay the problem factoring is in
TF and P because for every input string
there is a solution
now
um if you've seen or heard of tfnp
before you may have seen various
problems in subclasses that have
sometimes long abbreviations beginning
with p like PLS PPP Etc
all of these are actually come from a
very simple idea right suppose you have
an existence principle or a proof of
existence
of the following kind okay the you have
a proof of existence which says that for
any instance of a certain object for any
circuit for any graph for any integer
there exists an efficiently verifiable
solution for that instance
well then such a principle automatically
gives you a problem in tfnp okay and
this problem will be interesting if that
principle that existence principle
doesn't yield an efficient algorithm for
finding a solution because otherwise it
would just be in functional p
so with factoring for example the the
existence principle is the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic that every integer
has a finite set of factors or is prime
but the proof of that doesn't give you
an efficient way to find the factors of
any integer
great so that's sort of these kinds of
existence principles are what give rise
to all of these classes you've seen
before like PLS and ppad and so on now
in this talk we'll mostly be interested
in one which is local search
so the local search principle is the
following combinatorial existence
principle all right
it says that if applying some sort of
efficient step that increases on the an
objective on a finite domain if you have
a a a step like that that you can apply
that increases an objective and a finite
domain then a local Optimum must exist
okay
so it's a simple sort of basic set
theory principle because you can only
apply the objective increase or finite
number of times on the finite domain
so it gives rise to the following search
problem which we will call it or with
Source right so this is a concrete
problem now so given as input a
successor circuit under some fixed
representation of circuits a successor
circuit s from n bit strings to n bit
strings as well as a source string s
such that when you apply the circuit s
to little s you get something that's
bigger than S so we'll mean bigger and
less than as lexicographically bigger
than throughout this talk
and the solution is to find another
string v such that when you apply s to V
you get something bigger than V so s did
increase when applied to the point V but
when you apply s to S of V well then
that string is less than or equal to s
to b so you found a local Optimum uh
that local Optimum was the point s of V
okay so PLS is the class of search
problems that are polytime reducible to
it or with Source now if you if you know
PLS or tfnp from before you might say
wait this isn't the original complete
Problem by which PLS is defined and
that's true but it's not hard to show
that this is also uh complete for PLS
we'll Define it like this for now but
we'll see other uh complete problems for
PLS in a bit
now let's take a closer look at this
problem editor with source so I just
copied and pasted the definition here
um what we're going to do is we're going
to denote by S Sub I
the circuit you get by setting the first
input bit of s
2 I or I is either 0 or 1. so you set
the first input bit to zero one and then
you propagate that effect throughout the
circuit what do I mean by that I mean
you you feed forward through the layers
of the circuit so for example if there's
an and gate and now you have a zero
feeding into the end gate well then you
can replace that and gate with zero
right and then propagate it onwards or
if you had an or gate then you can
replace it by the other input just
directly feeding into wherever that or
gate fit into and so on a concrete
definition is given in the paper it's
very intuitive so you propagate it and
then you remove the last output bit
and when you propagate you also remove
any constants and everything at the end
so the point is you get a circuit that
is strictly smaller than the original
circuit you started with okay so
consider the following Oracle algorithm
for solving it or with source
all right and again for the resource you
have the successor circuit and a source
string as input
now if the source string has a leading
one
well then we have a source that is in
the second half of the domain so then we
can just query uh S Sub 1 where we set
the first input bit to one
with the source being the first n minus
one bits of s because already there's a
source in the second half so we can just
look for a sink in the second half and
that's a smaller instance
okay but otherwise we're going to query
S Sub 0 as well as uh with the source
being the first n minus one bits of s
now two things can happen one is that
this either gives you a solution to the
original instance or it'll give us a
false solution but if you think about it
a little bit
um you know if you pause this talk or go
to the paper it's all explained uh but
what is a false solution a false
solution
is something that wasn't actually a
local Optimum and the only way that
could happen is if
um is if it left the subdomain that we
queried on so the first half of the
input strings so in other words if you
get a false solution well then this
actually would give you a string S Prime
with a leading one such that s applied
to S Prime is greater than S Prime but
then you have a source in the second
half of the input strings right so then
you can query S Sub 1 with S Prime the
first n minus one bits of it and get a
solution to the original problem okay so
what does that all show that shows that
it or with source is DSR very
interesting now we have to be a bit
careful here because we're talking about
DSR for search problems now so let's
just review the definition in this
context
we say that a search problem R is DSR if
there is a polytime algorithm a solving
an instance x with an oracle for R but
on sub queries that are strictly smaller
in length than x now here's the extra
part and that succeeds so a succeeds
given any solutions to the sub queries
that a queries on because in the
decisional landscape you know the only
possible solutions are zero and one but
here there could be many solutions uh to
the search problem given any of them a
needs to succeed okay and so iterate
sources DSR in the sense
and so the natural question we asked
when we realized this is our other
problems in PLS DSR
and so the answer is sort of
uh so here's the original itter problem
uh and in this problem it's exactly the
same except we're not given the source
as an input to the problem okay instead
we're given the successor circuit such
that when you apply s to the zero string
it outputs something greater uh than the
zero string so in other words the zero
string is a source and it's the same
problem otherwise you have to find a v
that at v s increases but it doesn't
increase at s of B and now this problem
is also PLS complete but despite our
attempts it is not clear how to show
that this problem is DSR in the way I
previously defined
why not well what breaks down in the
proof if you try to sort of do the same
proof is that after the first Oracle
query on the first half of the sub of
the domain
if you got a false solution what did
that mean it meant that we got an S
Prime with the leading one such that s
supplied to S Prime is greater than S
Prime in other words it's a source in
the second half of the input strings and
that's great but the problem is that the
first n minus 1 bits of S Prime might
not be the zero string so it doesn't
actually match the input representation
of the iter problem and so we thought
about this like well can't you just like
shift all the inputs like shift them mod
uh 2 to the N over 2 or something like
that so that this string S Prime becomes
the zero strings but that actually
doesn't work or at least we didn't
figure out how to make that work
uh
uh but it is downward self-reducible in
a different way all right it is downward
self-reducible and that we can reduce
the smaller instances
where and smaller in the following sense
that they have less input and output
bits
so that's going to lead to the following
definition
so first of all a circuit problem is a
search problem where the input is always
interpreted as circuits so again we fix
some standard representation of circuit
say query circuit C from n Bits to n
Bits okay so we say that a circuit
problem R is circuit DSR
if there is a polytime algorithm a
solving an instant C from n Bits to M
bits with an oracle for r
where for each sub query of the
following form C Prime sub I which just
means there can be multiple of them from
n Prime bits to M Prime bits we have
that the sum of N prime plus M Prime is
less than n plus m in other words the
sub queries have less uh input and
output bits overall than the original
circuit okay and we also say that
um a problem is Circa DSR with poly
blowup if the sub queries C Prime are at
most the original circuit size of the
original circuit representation plus so
additively more uh polynomial in n and M
and so we have that the previous problem
error without the source provided is
circuit DSR with poly blow up even
though we can't show its DSR in the
strict sense
okay and the reason is that we shrink
the number of input and output bits but
the actual circuit itself grows a little
bit
now what about other PLS complete
problems so here's sort of the most
canonical one that if you've seen PLS
before you've probably seen the class
defined to this complete problem sync of
dat in sync of dag we're also given the
successor circuit from n Bits 10 bits
such that when applied to the zero
string it's not the zero string so zero
string is a source but we're also given
the valuation string from n bit strings
to numbers between 1 and 2 to the m just
the maximum evaluation
and we have to find a v
such that s applied to V isn't V but
either it's a sink so s applied to S of
V is s of e okay or we found a local
Optimum with respect to this valuation
so V apply to S of V is less than the
valuation of V
um if this isn't so important if you
haven't seen this before or didn't
internalize this definition when I said
it but the point is that this problem is
PLS complete and we show that sync of
dag is also circuit DSR with poly blow
up once again we don't know how to show
that it's DSR in the strict sense of
shrinking the full input size and we
show uh circuit DSR with poly blob for
uh some other PLS complete problems as
well but these are just the most
important ones
so
you know what's the next natural
question to ask ourselves great we've
shown PL uh DSR or circuit DSR for these
PLS complete problems the question is is
every PLS complete problem DSR or
circuit DSR and the answer is we don't
know and we don't know because we don't
really know how to show something like
that and one of the main reasons is that
DSR is a property that is not preserved
under polynomial uh time reductions
and it's a very simple reason because
when you apply a polytime reduction the
uh
the instance you get of the problem you
reduced to could have blown up it could
have become like Square the original
size of the uh the original instance so
then even if that's DSR you won't be
able to shrink it down enough to make
the original problem DSR so somehow it
doesn't work and in fact the analogous
problem in the decisional landscape is
also open so it's open whether every NP
or every P space complete problem is DSR
so we sort of don't know but it's an
interesting problem
but then here's the next actual question
so we said okay we don't know that well
the next the other natural question is
the converse is it true that every DSR
problem in tfnp is in PLS
and it turns out that the answer is yes
so we prove the following theorems we
prove that if a problem in tfnp is DSR
then it is in PLS
and we also prove and this is sort of
comforting that if a problem in tfnp is
circuit DSR with poly blowup then it is
also in PLS so for purposes of uh you
know inside of tfnp in membership to
these classes DSR and circuit DSR are
both good they both give you membership
in PLS
um so what does this mean again remember
this thing about properties and complete
problems what does it mean that there
are complete problems in PLS that are
DSR and DSR guarantees membership in PLS
well we can rephrase it with the
following Corollary
we know that if PLS is hard either in
the worst case or any average case sense
uh that is true if and only if a DSR
problem in tfnp is hard with the same
notion of hardness so we've like given a
new characterization of hardness of the
class PLS which has to do with local
search
great uh so here's kind of a very quick
sketch of this theorem that DSR implies
PLS
so if a problem R is DSR
then it has a very inefficient recursive
algorithm and it's the obvious one what
you do is you run the Oracle algorithm
recursively so on all the Oracle sub
queries you just run the algorithm again
and so on it's very inefficient
but
um generally here's the interesting
thing about tfnp complexity and this is
something probably told me some time ago
and I've kind of been repeating it ever
since but I do want to give them credit
for this observation that reduction uh
reductions to tfnp problems are all
about exploiting inefficient but very
structured algorithms so these
algorithms would be too inefficient to
show that these problems are in anything
other than like TF and P subclasses
because they're inefficient but they
have some structure to them so they give
you a reduction to PLS or p-pad or one
of these problems guaranteed by an
existential argument
so the idea to this reduction is just to
simulate the inefficient recursive
algorithm as a walk on the graph all
right and the nodes of this graph are
just going to be the states of the
inefficient algorithm so what we mean by
that is the list of the sub queries so
far with the solutions for each one
except for the last sub query issued for
which you know we append the
sub-computation of the recursive
algorithm on that last sub query and it
sort of goes down like that
and the details are in the paper about
this very simple idea allows us to show
that DSR implies membership in PLS
great so now let's kind of change gears
a little bit and go back to talking
about the fact about factoring so let's
recall the factoring problem uh given an
integer n a solution is either all of
the non-trivial factors and this time
we're going to require that uh they're
provided in decreasing order
or the word Prime if n is prime
all right so if you think about our
results already imply that if factoring
is DSR then it is in PLS
and this is interesting because it is
unknown whether there is a downward soft
reduction for factoring is there an
efficient algorithm for factoring that
works by querying smaller numbers a no
one interesting and if it were true it
would be in PLS which would be
surprising and I'll touch on that later
uh but here's something else in this
problem factoring Solutions are also
unique right factoring isn't only in
tfnp meaning that for every input string
there's an output but also those outputs
are unique because we require this
decreasing order thing
um so we can strengthen our results what
we found is that we can actually
strengthen our result for DSR problems
in the class tfup which is just the
problems in tfnp with unique Solutions
and I'll show you exactly what that
result is in a second
so this is sort of the most confusing
side of the talk but it'll all make
sense
um there's a very important problem in
the study of tfnp especially the crypto
tfnp called synca verifiable or verified
line or svl right and this problem we're
given the successor circuit as before as
well as a Target integer t
and we're going to try to find the teeth
node you get by applying as T times
now you're also provided a verifier
circuit V which takes in an N bit string
as well as a number from 1 to T and
output 0 or 1. and it has the following
promise so SEL is a promise problem it's
a promise problem the promise is that V
apply to X and the number I is 1 if and
only if this X
Is What You Get by applying s i times to
the zero string which will be our source
okay so and the solution to the sdl
problem it would be the unique string v
such that V is the T node in this line
in other words that V the verifier
applied to V and uh the target T gives
you one okay so once again V would be S
apply T times to the zero string so svl
is a promise problem all right and it's
not even in tfnp you have an instance so
you don't it's not guaranteed to have a
solution because the promise might be
false
but a very clever idea from the field of
reversible computation called the
pebbling strategy can be used to
transform valid instances of svl into a
problem called unique end of potential
line which is in tfnp there's a line of
paper showing this and the idea is very
neat and elegant and has to do with
reversible computation so I invite
anyone interested to look at that
um and if I had time I would I would
present it in this presentation because
I think it's very nice uh but this
problem unique end of potential line is
in a class called CLS which we now know
is actually the intersection of PLS
which we've been studying in this
presentation and another very important
subclass in tfnp called ppad
so this class is very very low in the
hierarchy of classes of tfnp it's very
down low
um and there's a rich line of work which
shows hardness in tfnp from various
cryptographic assumptions and you may
have seen these papers showing hardness
and tfnp or sometimes they'll say
showing hardness to Nash equilibrium or
something like that from IO or from
discrete log now or like from different
things from different kinds of succinct
non-interactive arguments of knowledge
and so on all of these crypto
assumptions or hardness assumptions
showing hardness in tfnp all of these
papers are actually constructing hard
instances of this problem
UE opl Unique Kind of potential line via
constructing instances of This Promise
problem svl so kind of on the side is
that it's interesting that all of these
results we have about connecting crypto
hardness assumptions to tfnp hardness
all of them have to do with constructing
svl instances which give you hard tfnp
problems very very low in the hierarchy
so these assumptions are very strong and
give you a hardness of a problem that's
very very low and that's how they all
work and our result is no different so
what we show
is that if there is a problem R and T in
uh unique tfnp and it is DSR then it is
reducible to sync a verifiable line and
hence in particular to this problem
unique end of potential line
and so a coral area of this is that for
any I got any unique uh problem such as
factoring if it has a downward
self-reduction and in fact we can
strengthen this a little bit if there is
any algorithm for factoring by creating
numbers that are smaller by any
multiplicative constant okay then
factoring is an unique at the potential
line
but this problem is in CLS
well just once again PLS intersect ppad
so this would really be a big deal right
and this sort of here's a schematic a
simplified schematic of tfnp
and the reason this would be so
surprising is because factoring or
version factoring star here means
versions of the factoring problem are
known to be in two classes that are sort
of high up here called PPP for
pigeonhole principle and PPA which are
parity argument and both of these
classes uh contain uh the subclass p-pad
people have been working for a while and
showing that factoring is in the class P
pad by kind of trying to exploit one of
those inefficient algorithms for
factoring
um but we haven't been able to do that
whereas if someone came up with a
downward self-reduction for Factor angle
then you would have that factoring as an
unique end of potential line so it would
be in a class much lower than p-pad uh
which would be quite surprising
so what are open questions that this
work leads to uh so we'd like to think
that in this work we've initiated the
study of downward self-reducibility in
tfnp
now can we show DSR or circuit DSR in
this for more PLS complete problems or
maybe problems actually lower than PLS
interestingly there's reason to think
that unique end of potential line is DSR
and that actually may be easy to show
more generally would be interesting to
understand the relationship between DSR
and circuit DSR for circuit problems
it's probably very hard but if these
Notions are equivalent that would be
very interesting
now here's another open problem sort of
my favorite one from these another kind
of self-reducibility that's very
important is random self-producibility
or rsr now the definitions vary but I
mean intuitively what it means is that
given an instance there's a way to solve
it like uh if by querying let's say
uniformly random inputs to the problem
and if you're given solutions to those
ones you can figure out the solution to
the original instance so like sort of a
worst case to average case reduction so
uh many important algebraic problems
that are in tfnp are rsr right such as
discrete log rsan version and so on
these are problems that are actually
sort of weaker problems than factoring
as in lower in the hierarchy because if
you can break factoring you can do those
so the question is uh can you place rsr
problems that are in tfnp in some
subclass so a very natural candidate to
me seems to be the class PPP for
pigeonhole problems sort of the reason
being that the problems in tfnp that we
know are rsr such as discrete log and
RSA there they are in PPP so it would
seem like maybe actually any rsr problem
is in PPP and the way to do that would
be to exploit this very inefficient
algorithm uh for solving
um rsr problems but that is structured
and that algorithm is you know given an
input like randomly sample some other
inputs I get solutions to those and so
on so maybe there's a way to show that
those problems are in PPP great I hope
this was interesting thank you very much
and
um please read the paper if you are
interested in more thank you